I grew up in the american south..
Maybe not the heart of it, but close enough
to see and experience a setting and environment
around me, that I caught closer glimpses of
when my family traveled deeper into the south…
a setting and environment that is very rarely
represented in movies.
This is why I think I’ve been so drawn to
writer and director Jeff Nichols’ filmography.
A native of arkansas, there’s a character
that ties all of Nichols’ films together.
And I’m not talking about Michael Shannon,
although their five film collaboration has
produced some of his best roles.
All of Nichols films are set and shot in the
south, with the exception of Take Shelter
(but more on that one later).
Shotgun Stories, Nichols first film sets up
the story of a feud between broken families
in arkansas.
The decay of the area helps mirror the lack
of hope for anything better that drives the
characters towards conflict.
Nichols third film Mud, is as much named after
the setting as the main character.
Set and shot along the Mississippi river in
Arkansas the location seeps through every
pore of the film.
Midnight Special spans more territory than
Nichols’ other films, but placing the climactic
moments in Louisiana, brings the director
back into comfortable territory.
And finally with Loving, set in Virginia near
where I grew up, Nichols looks at the south
not just as a setting but as a subject.
Bringing some of the underlying conflicts
of the location out of subtext, and addressing
them clearly.
When I watched Mud, the first of Nichols films
that I saw, I immediately recognized a part
of the south that I’d seen, and experienced
in real life, but had never seen reflected
in a film before.
The south isn’t a favorite of Hollywood’s
but it’s gotten it’s fair share of exposure
over the years.
However, it’s representation is limited.
Most films have portrayed the historic south,
an idealized idyllic version of the south,
or an upper class version of the south.
But none of these were the south I knew.
Jeff Nichols image of the south is a south
that I recognize.
It’s a south where disenchanted men work
manual labor jobs, where the idea of “living
off the land” still exists as an ideal even
after industrialization reared its head, and
then left the area in shambles.
It’s a south where the touch of man did
not create beautiful cities and parks, but
came, used the land and it’s inhabitants,
and left scars and broken people.
Where men, now abandoned by other richer men,
do what they can to scrape by.
It’s a troubled place with it’s problems.
But it’s people, perhaps inexplicably, love
it.
They find identity and pride in the place.
They dream, not of escaping, but of bettering
themselves and the land where they grew up.
This south is one where a return to nature
is still revered.
Nichols shows all this, the beauty and the
scars, with the same loving gaze.
There isn’t a judgement, just a tenderness.
For the people, for the places.
He doesn’t shy away from the damage and
the problems, but he also doesn’t inflate
them into caricatures or suck all humanity
out of the setting.
I’ve seen some use the term “Southern
Gothic” to describe Nichols films.
And that strikes me as a little funny.
The elements present in Nichols’ south,
if they were exaggerated could constitute
southern gothic.
But anyone who describes Nichols work as such
hasn’t seen how real his south is.
These themes are so grounded in Nichols work
that even when he sets a story outside of
the south, like he did with Take Shelter,
set and shot in Ohio, he still looks at the
land and the people with the same gaze.
I even found Take Shelter incorrectly included
on a list of “best southern movies.”
Ohio becomes a facsimile of Nichols image
of the south, differentiated only by name.
Nichols uses the visual language of his films
to communicate aspects of the settings.
In shotgun stories and in Loving, the stillness
and slowness of the pacing communicate the
slower pace of life.
Often shots don’t move, they just rest.
And he’s films are mostly shot outside under
natural sunlight, leaning heavily on nature
for locations.
In Mud he uses slow steadicam movement throughout
the film to mimic the slow flowing of the
mississippi river, reinforcing how it’s
at the heart of this area.
Nichol’s south isn’t a complete picture
of the place, it isn’t meant to be.
But it’s a picture of a facet of an area
I rarely see anywhere else.
It’s a picture that obviously Nichols himself
is in love with.
One that clearly is meaningful to him.
And I think it’s one that clearly is put
forth by someone who understands the place,
who themselves, is a product of the south.
I’m not a die hard fan of the south, perhaps
because I wasn’t born there.
You wouldn’t have to do much to lure me
back into the north or out west.
But the image of those who are rooted in this
place is one that I recognize and one that
I can sympathize with.
And I think it’s one that’s rarely understood
well enough to be portrayed accurately.
I don’t think hollywood has intentionally
ignored this image of the south.
It’s just a matter of writing what you know.
And it took someone who understood that image
to film there and express it clearly.
I think this shows the importance of localized
voices.
How smaller artists can represent an area
authentically in a way nobody else has.
And I hope Nichols is the kind of director
we’ll see more
of
in
the future of film.